cheese butter is the delicious gourmet
cheese melt that blends four indulgent
cheeses and seasoned butter i love this
stuff perfect on bread bagels sandwiches
veggies and more and you'll get 20 off
when you go to cheesebutter.com
pacman the link is down below well i
hope it was a great passover weekend for
people who celebrate
um easter weekend etc
except for a lot of people it wasn't
good we had not won not two not three
not four not five
but ten mass shootings in the united
states over the easter weekend ten mass
shootings three of which were
prominent enough to make national news
but a total of 10 different mass
shootings some
particularly horrible and it is yet
another reminder of this completely out
of control gun violence problem that
exists in the united states i'm going to
tell you a little bit about some of
these incidents so the guardian
reporting about three of these now some
of these were not
these terms are really crazy
some of these were not major enough mass
shootings that they got national
attention some only got local attention
uh the guardian reporting u.s rocked by
three separate mass shootings over
easter weekend actually it was ten
two teenage boys killed in pittsburgh in
one of at least three shootings over the
weekend including two in south carolina
south carolina didn't just have one
easter mass shooting they had two easter
mass shootings
in pittsburgh two teenage boys killed
and eight others wounded after gunfire
erupted at a party in a short-term
rental home in pittsburgh early sunday
the other two shootings both in south
carolina left a total of 18 people with
bullet wounds once again reigniting
calls among advocates for meaningful gun
control legislation now remember at any
time if you're morbidly curious about
the sad state of gun violence in the
united states you can go to
gunviolencearchive.org and on that
website not only can you see a list of
all recent shootings
meaning mass shootings and and non-mass
shootings
you can also see
the mass shooting specifically and the
details and as you will see here
yesterday
easter sunday we had a shooting in
pittsburgh
miami
portland
furman south carolina sacramento
california and philadelphia pennsylvania
two mass shootings in pennsylvania
yesterday one in philly where four
people were injured and the one i
mentioned in pittsburgh were two were
killed and eight were injured on
saturday the day before easter we saw
mass shootings in syracuse new york
baltimore maryland columbia south
carolina and north las vegas nevada
and then on good friday we were lucky
enough to have only one mass shooting in
the united states in stockton california
now with any of these on gun violence
archive you can click on the view
incident or view source information so
for example if we look at miami
it tells us where the shooting took
place and who the victims were gender
age etc and what the circumstances were
this one noting that it was a teen party
a teen party was the location of this
shooting this is absolutely insane and
maybe the most frustrating thing about
this
is the resignation with which you know
it's this we we joke we're we haven't
tried anything yet and we're all out of
ideas
uh we've had all sorts of different
proposals and i'll be the first to tell
you i mean listen number one we have a
second amendment you're not just going
to ban guns that shouldn't even be what
the left tries to do because you're not
going to do it we have a second
amendment but we have so many things
that could be done
that would without a doubt reduce the
number of shooting deaths wouldn't
eliminate them of course you're always
going to have people who obtain guns
illegally that that's always the case
but
if there are fewer guns in the system
there are fewer guns which can be
obtained illegally and we saw after the
sandy hook shooting in connecticut
during barack obama's presidency
90 of the country said i mean listen
universal background checks a background
check for any gun transaction even
personal transactions if i sell a gun to
my friend
i should still
have some system where i can easily
run a required background check before i
sell them a gun
maybe i don't know everything about my
friend limits on ammunition
uh
requirements in terms of insurance we
require insurance in most states
in order to drive a vehicle why wouldn't
we require insurance for owning guns
what about re-licensing not just you do
a weekend and get you then you get your
fid card and that's it but re-licensing
the way we do
with driver's license i mean there's so
much low-hanging fruit
and the right has very successfully
framed the debate
as
any gun safety regulations should on
principle be opposed and are violations
of the second amendment now of course
that's not true
it it's just not the case we have a
second amendment and the second
amendment remains in place but we have a
really sick situation and a lot of this
as i've spoken about before and this
relates to a lot of other issues we talk
about
we have a broken culture in the united
states
too many people
see guns as a valid solution to problems
interpersonal problems
social problems
political problems we've talked about
that we also can't ignore
untreated and undiagnosed mental health
in the united states as well as lack of
access to mental health services as well
as stigma around getting treatment for
mental health it's not the way the right
likes to say
just a mental health problem of
individuals no
but it is part of it for sure and it's a
lot of different things together compare
that to a country like switzerland where
it's not you know the right loves to say
switzerland has tons of guns and they
don't have a mass shooting problem well
but hold on a second look at the
required training in in switzerland
look at the health care system in
switzerland
look at the culture in switzerland where
it would be seen as bonkers to consider
using a firearm to solve an
interpersonal or political problem in
the united states we have an entire
political movement based around no
violence is valid as a way to solve
problems so when the right says it's
just mental health it's not but that's a
component culture is a component etc
think back to the kyle rittenhouse thing
as i've said before
it makes sense based on the facts that
he was acquitted
we said that from the beginning based on
the way self-defense laws are written it
makes sense that he was acquitted but it
is a failure of parenting it's a failure
of gun culture it's a failure of so many
different things and that is pretty
unique to the united states maybe it
exists in some other countries which we
wouldn't typically compare ourselves to
i'm not sure
but it is it is quite a quite a
disturbing situation here
the next front
in the culture war against education
is florida's new battle against math
textbooks david what the hell are you
talking about
has florida gone crazy yeah
yeah but that's not new
um the new situation in florida is that
the florida department of education
announced going into the weekend
that they are now rejecting more than 50
math textbooks not history that they
don't like how it's being taught
not human geography or social studies
they're rejecting more than 50 math
textbooks citing references to critical
race theory among reasons for rejecting
these books the department has rejected
54 out of 132 textbook submissions
because they don't adhere to the new
standards in florida or because they
contain so-called prohibited topics
this is
um the the reasons they are saying are
the books have critical race theory in
them
they include common core
they include unsolicited editions of
social emotional learning in mathematics
now asked for examples i've been unable
to find even a single one and this is
the new fight they're saying math is
being taught with a basis in marxism
they're saying math is attempted to be
taught with a basis in critical race
theory
and you may remember that florida
banned
these words
even though the language being used is
so stupid florida banned the teaching of
critical race theory in schools in june
now of course critical race theory
wasn't being taught in schools but what
they will say when pressed and they're
going to say the same thing with the
math books you say well but where was
critical race theory a subject
they'll say no no david it's much more
pernicious than that i go right into my
alex jones voice it's much more
pernicious than that
it's that they use critical race theory
as a framework to teach history it's not
that it's a subject and similarly
uh they're they're using it to teach
math i you know i remember when i was in
school you always had these funny math
examples calvin butterball
eats six apples
you remember these i don't know what the
critical race theory version is juan has
four oranges
is juan a dangerous illegal i mean i
like i don't even understand what what
is it that they want to see in these
books and of course they're offended
they're outraged
this can't be this is terrible for our
children and when we say well can you
give an example of the critical race
theory in the math books they don't they
don't say and conveniently and i don't
want to pretend that this is just about
money but textbooks are a big big
industry it just so happens that when
you look at the whitelisted textbooks
um
there's a bunch of
some of them are actually florida
textbooks
that
i i don't i don't we want to look into
it more but there's always potentially
some kind of cronyistic hey we'll make
sure that your textbook is the one that
gets purchased here um
this is the new fight
and what really pains me about this is
that this works look at virginia
look at the virginia gubernatorial
election that we had where glenn younkin
ran on banning critical race theory from
virginia schools and it convinced people
and many people voted for him for that
reason there's no critical race theory
being taught in virginia there wasn't
any way
now sure
youngkin's opponent terry mcauliffe made
some mistakes
like you know running against trump when
trump wasn't a candidate and youngen
didn't endure didn't embrace trump that
was a big mistake from democrats but
when you interviewed voters they said oh
yeah no i'm concerned about what's going
on in education critical race theory
[Music]
they fell for it and they voted for
yunkan so this stuff works
and with desantis up for re-election as
governor in 2022 this year
and with desantis the number one
challenger to donald trump in polling
for the 2024 republican nomination there
is no doubt that he knows this stuff
works and they're going to keep pushing
it let me know your thoughts you can
find me on twitter at deepakman also
tomorrow tomorrow it's already it's
already almost come and gone the next
david pakman show viewer town hall is
tomorrow tuesday april 19th
at 6 p.m eastern it'll be streaming live
on the pacman live youtube channel i
hope to see you there
one of our sponsors today is cheese
butter i love this stuff cheese butter
is a delicious gourmet cheese melt that
ingeniously blends
four indulgent cheeses and aromatically
seasoned butter
all the ingredients the cheese the
butter the seasonings are sourced for
the highest quality you can really taste
that this was made with fresh simple
high shelf ingredients nothing
artificial
cheese on bread right i mean come on and
butter on bread
why wouldn't i love cheese butter put it
on french bread sourdough bagels english
muffin jewish rye pumpernickel
sandwiches grilled cheese burgers baked
potatoes mac and cheese broccoli veggies
cheese butter is a business that
supports the david pakman show support
them their product is really fantastic
it's been a secret recipe in their
family for 50 years
taste it for yourself to really
understand what it's about
i don't think you'll be sorry and you'll
now get 20 off when you go to
cheesebutter.com
pacman the link is down below
the david pakman show is a viewer and
listener supported program we depend on
you to do what we do every single
weekday produce a one-hour show and a
15-minute extra show for our members and
you can sign up and support our work at
joinpacman.com i would love to see you
join the ranks of membership all right
some of you are going to be mad at me
for covering the story but i would be a
partisan hypocrite if i didn't cover
this story except the other half of you
are going to be mad at me for covering
this story the way that i'm going to
cover it there is a video floating
around in which the story goes joe biden
appears very very visibly confused at a
speech last week where after speaking he
turned and he tried to shake hands with
thin air and then looked so confused on
the stage and didn't know where to go
and he has dementia and he has
alzheimer's and it's worse than trump
and all of this different stuff and i'll
tell you when over the weekend the clip
was sent to me and i looked at it on my
small phone screen
very quickly
it looked very bad
joe biden looked confused it looked like
he was shaking hands with the air
thinking there was someone standing next
to him and there was no one there and i
was getting ready to come to you and say
guys i mean listen we have a dozen
examples of trump with this type of
stuff i've got to tell you that we have
one with joe biden
except then i actually looked at the
video that was not cropped uh into a
sort of uh a vertical video where you
actually see the sides of what's going
on
and um
it actually it is fine
joe biden is very clearly speaking to
people on different sides of him and
signaling to them with his hand yes it
looks weird he's sticking it out almost
like a handshake but he points to the
people uh to the right and he turns
around and he points to people that were
over his left shoulder and over his
right shoulder and that's just kind of
it i mean it's we're going to look at it
and um
once i saw the full video it really just
kind of seems like no big deal so i'm
going to play it for you
and i know that if you're only listening
you're not really going to get the full
picture of this but let's take a look at
it and then i'll explain it and we'll go
from there nothing america can't do
when we do it together as the united
states of america
god bless you all
[Music]
so i mean listen i i was i was ready to
say
something's wrong with joe biden we
gotta evaluate joe biden
but when you actually look at what he's
doing
he he's engaging with each wing of the
crowd and he's saying something i don't
know if it's like how was it or uh
thanks for being here but he's very
clearly turning to the people on his
right and he says something and then he
turns and faces back and he does the
exact same thing you see his arm do the
exact so i don't want to be labor this
but
it's not what it initially appeared to
be that that's just kind of it and i
would tell you guys when trump looked
confused and lost right when trump got
off of his plane
and his limos his car is right in front
of him
and he seems to wander off
and literally a secret service agent
comes over and takes him by the arm and
turns him around and walks him back
towards his car
he seemed very confused and there was no
real simple explanation for that
when donald trump said he wanted to know
the oranges of an investigation and he
kind of like glitches and he knows that
what's coming out of his mouth doesn't
make sense he wants to say origins and
he's saying oranges
and he tries again and it doesn't
that was really weird there's been no
real explanation for that not even a
simple one when rudy giuliani was
sitting right across from trump at a
table and trump says where is rudy and
he's looking around and rudy's as close
as you know not as close as my
microphone but right across the table
there was no explanation for that and
and i told you that
and when joe biden has completely lost
his train of thought i've told you that
really doesn't look good that's not his
stutter joe biden has had a lifelong
stutter
when he completely loses his train of
thought
and says well okay let me move on
because they don't want me talking about
this it just seems like he's losing his
train of thought and i've told you guys
um
this video
is not
what many are making it out to be um
what what i uh
i i don't i don't even know what else to
say does biden sometimes sound confused
yeah he does and i don't like when it
happens it makes me uncomfortable does
sometimes uh does joe biden sometimes
lose his train of thought yeah
absolutely but this video as the smoking
gun dementia video
i i just don't see it guys if you
disagree with me i want you to let me
know
kentucky
has now essentially banned abortion in
the state this is almost certainly a
violation of roe v wade but the supreme
court is going to rule in what is at
this point only weeks
whether roe v wade is essentially gone
and that's the really scary part of this
vox reporting it is now practically
impossible to get an abortion in
kentucky a new law is forcing the
state's last remaining abortion
providers to shut down
vox reporting kentucky ended virtually
all in-state abortions wednesday
enacting a sweeping law that bans
abortions after 15 weeks of pregnancy
restricts minors access to the procedure
and cracks down on medication abortions
it's now the state with the harshest
abortion restrictions in the united
states the new law goes into effect
immediately it will force the state's
two remaining abortion clinics in
louisville to close due to onerous new
requirements on doctors forcing
kentuckians to look elsewhere for
abortion care so
again this almost certainly violates roe
v wade roe v wade says
that
the constitution
protects women's liberty to choose to
have an abortion
without excessive government restriction
now
excessive government restriction
is the source of much controversy and
opens itself up to significant
interpretation so
excessive restriction allows some
restriction but not too much
and under roe v wade
closing putting such onerous
requirements on abortion providers such
that they all close
would without a doubt in any sensible
interpretation of roe v wade be
considered to be uh unconstitutional
that that's onerous if the if the
requirements are so strict that every
provider in the state closes and people
seeking an abortion have to go to a
different state
that would violate roe v wade
by any sensible interpretation
but
this will be appealed of course
but in so in that process during that
process the supreme court might decide
in june
we are going to effectively overturn roe
v wade by allowing extremely harsh state
laws to stand
roe v wade could be gone in a few weeks
and as is often the case
in red states that are trying to ban
abortion
many of those states are an economic and
educational and health care disaster
i've said this so many times before the
states that are obsessed with these
cultural issues
are disastrous states by almost every
metric if you look at kentucky for
example kentucky is 43rd out of 50
in terms of healthcare
kentucky is 40th out of 50 in terms of
its economy
kentucky is 48th out of 50 in fiscal
stability
44th in education and 47th in terms of
poverty rate
and yet their focus is let's try to ban
abortion
we've talked before
at minimum at minimum if you want to ban
abortion you should include all sorts of
support for the expectant mothers and
parents
because all of these additional children
being born that folks
in theory wanted to uh uh not have born
so you're going to give them financial
support right well no no no that that's
not right either and this all ties back
i haven't used the i used to talk about
this a lot i haven't for some period of
time this is what's called strict father
morality you know the strict dad who
says well
it's the principle it's the principle
they want to control women's bodies they
have a religious view on uh you know
sexual intercourse is supposed to be
strictly for procreation
and they're against comprehensive sex
education and often they're against
contraception so so that doesn't all
wait but you you don't want
abortion
but you also don't want to do the things
to prevent unintended pregnancy what do
you want and they say well we want
procreative sex in the context of
marriage and anything outside of that
means one needs to suffer the
consequences that's the right morality
if you get pregnant you've got to have
the kid and you've got to deal with
paying for all of the expenses of the
kid as well
wait but so
that doesn't make sense because we know
that one of the best ways to prevent
unwanted pregnancy
is
total and complete access to
contraception
comprehensive sex education that's how
you prevent unwanted pregnancy excellent
study out of st louis looked at this oh
no but that wouldn't be the right
morality because that would open the
door
to people just having sex and that no no
no that doesn't go with our morality
it's uh completely backwards
it is antiquated thinking it is
non-science thinking but horrifyingly
and particularly if the supreme court
decision at the end of june effectively
reverses roe v wade
this is going to be the law of the land
in many many red states now as i've said
before
what should the people in these states
do
because on the one hand
one approach would be well we need
progressives and center-left democrats
and whatever to move to these states to
change the laws by becoming involved in
local government yeah but that's a big
uphill battle it's almost easier to say
to the folks who are rational and clear
thinking
leave those states and go to a blue
state
but the problem is a lot of people can't
afford to do that so it really is a
disastrous situation i don't know
what the abortion landscape is going to
look like say 12 months from now a big
piece of that is because we don't know
what the supreme court will decide in a
few weeks and another part of that is we
don't know to what degree
red states will continue pushing these
types of laws every indication is that
red states are determined to push this
stuff another reason yet as if we needed
more reasons yet another reason
why the upcoming midterm elections are
so consequential and by that i mean it's
not just about who we elected the u.s
senate and the u.s house of
representatives but there are tons of
local elections as well that are going
to set the tone governor's races state
senates state houses of representatives
we will talk about it more we'll talk
about what's at stake but it is a very
very big deal we'll have more on this
on our instagram you can find the david
pakman show on instagram
by searching david pakman show on
instagram
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
seth moskowitz who's a journalist
writing about american politics and
technology and an editor at persuasion
magazine he's also author of the article
the reactionary trap which i've talked
about before with my audience seth
really great having you on today thank
you very much for having me i'm excited
to be here so i mean just just to start
with let's talk about
um i have made the case to my audience
that much of what is currently
associated with the american right wing
is not really conservative by any
definition of the term but is really a
sort of neo-reactionary movement can you
talk a little bit about when we say
reactionary what what are the
characteristics of a reactionary
political movement or proceed or
positions
yeah well fundamentally what a
reactionary is somebody who wants to go
back to the way things were before
politically or socially essentially they
want to roll back the clocks so where a
progressive might want to see some form
of change to to push things into the
future conservative might be a little
bit more focused on tradition and
skeptical of change but maybe more open
to it a reactionary somebody who wants
to roll back the clocks to the way
things were before
and so in my article i lay out two
things that i think kind of are
hallmarks of a reactionary the first is
that they lose sight of any sense of
proportionality um something that they
see as a threat
they are unable to kind of judge if it's
a five alarm fire or if it's something
that's kind of a minor threat that they
should be minorly concerned about
and the second is that their politics
becomes one of opposition
they lose sight of their their
principles and their values and the
things that they want to see in the
world and they become focused only on
opposing things that they dislike
now in hearing that it really sounds
like trumpism right i mean like when i
hear you say that i think okay so
a movement of opposition here's
something joe biden wants to do nope
we're not gonna we don't want him to do
that here's something uh barack obama
did no here's why we're gonna undo it
without really bringing policy proposals
to the table and also the fear piece
which is
critical race theory is going to be a
disaster with no proportionality in
terms of is it actually something that's
being taught
trans bathroom issues or trans women in
sports with no sense of the scope of
these issues am i right in
applying it in this way
yeah i think so and i think the
important thing that i've noticed is
that really what it feels like to me is
our dividing line in politics seems to
be this culture war and i think what
happens with reactionaries as they kind
of glom on to
the the politics of the day and the
things that's making people most furious
and most angry and today that's the
culture war and social issues so when i
think about who is a reactionary in
contemporary politics i don't think
about what their positions are on tax
policy or health care as much because
really like it seems like today in
politics you can kind of have opinions
on
those issues and be on left or right
what really matters and what really
feels like the dividing line in politics
today
is cultural issues and social issues so
the reactionaries that i see are focused
like you said on um critical race theory
in school on
the current
fear about gender being taught in
elementary schools
black lives matter all these cultural
social issues that seem to have taken
over our politics today i think those
are where reactionaries are glomming
onto when are really tacking and saying
we see these changes that are happening
and we want to go back to the world
before those changes were happening
now in the article the reactionary trap
which we will link to
you also point out the left is not
immune from this
and also that social media
has a role to play
in kind of creating these
fear-based reactionary almost like
feedback loops so can you talk about
that a little bit
yeah so in article i talk about a few
people who were
on the left and kind of jumped the shark
and became reactionaries like i was
speaking about on these cultural and
social issues and the point that i
wanted to make is that i think that
people on the left need to be aware that
it's possible for them to become
reactionary even if they think look i'm
left on health care i'm left on gun
issues i'm on the left so i can't be a
reactionary they need to be aware that
because the dividing line in politics
today seems to be these social issues if
you become a reactionary on
somehow every single one of these social
issues um it's possible that maybe
you're no longer a member of the left
but you become sort of a reactionary and
that you need to be aware of of this so
that maybe you can kind of
avoid
a politics that only relies on
opposition and and is only based on fear
and you need to start to have a positive
vision for maybe what you want your
politics to look like and you want the
country to look like um and so
essentially the article talked about a
few people these people who were on the
left and sort of sublimated they skipped
the middle phase and became
reactionaries on the right and it would
and they i think a big part of what
happened to them is that they got
involved on twitter they started to get
a feedback loop of people who were
rewarding them for criticizing the left
on social issues they built up an
audience of those type of people and
then they were unable to criticize the
left on any issues and they sort of
became reactionaries
out without any any real thought about
what was happening to them just by
following their instincts and following
their social media following
yeah i can kind of understand how it can
happen because you know over the last
many years i've waded into topics like
for example when the term regressive
left was a big thing
i was glad to say hey you know what
there is this thing of people who
operate under the label of being left
but they're really quite authoritarian
and that's not a leftism that i
recognize right for example which to me
is relatively uncontroversial like these
things exist in any political movement
and there was a reaction a very loud
reaction from a slice of my audience
focused exclusively on that which if i
had just latched on to that it probably
would have pulled me into a completely
different audience maybe it would have
been lucrative maybe it would have
allowed growth i was only interested in
going as far as i believe the facts
suggested on that but it seems like you
can you will very quickly start hearing
from a slice of your audience and they
will pull you towards those views
i think that's 100 right and it's
oftentimes going to be the loudest and
most active part of your audience and so
you're going to see all these people
reacting to the thing that you said that
was maybe the most exciting and you're
going to say oh wow maybe this is like
what's getting my audience excited i
should give them more of this content
it's called audience capture and i think
it's something that the blue checks on
twitter
and a lot of these people
who are maybe more reactionary on their
social views get a lot of a response
from those people on twitter and they
get really pulled into that world and i
don't think it's i don't think it's only
something that happens on the right i
think it could happen on the left too
and i think it just happens to be that
it's the most radical sides of either
base that really really is the most
active on twitter and on social media
and it's really pulling people to the
most
to the most
radical parts of their party or to their
social movement um and i think it's
honestly particularly noticeable on the
right on twitter um only because
it's it it seems like
it brings out the most vile part of
people and it really gets them excited
so you see it on twitter
when you're just when you're scrolling
through and it gives you an emotional
reaction
and you end
and
pulls out the side of you
that wants to respond and wants to get
engaged and i think it's important to
take a step back and say whoa this isn't
how the world actually is this is just a
certain portion of twitter that's really
this reactionary and this
grotesque yeah and i've i find that i
will often get questions like as an
example there were i don't know if you
remember this but shortly after trump
was elected in 2016 we saw the rise of
the women's march and then there was
this controversy where some of the
women's march leaders felt that jewish
women were sort of like not
intersectional enough or not
discriminated against enough to qualify
for like board or leadership membership
i called that out wholeheartedly and
talked about you know the dismissal of
anti-semitism and and jewish anti-jewish
discrimination but i also recognize like
this is a pretty small slice of the left
it was sort of like an attempt to keep
that proportionality in check as you
mentioned
yeah i think that's really important i
think there was a study that does done
um the hidden tribe study and it said
like seven percent of of users on
twitter are the most
are progressive activists about seven
percent are conservative reactionaries
or something equivalent on the right but
that they create the vast majority of
the content on twitter um and i think
that's because
one they're probably the most excited
about their political projects the most
active and two i think that they make it
so that the rest of the users on twitter
are fearful of of saying anything or are
fearful of using the platform because
they might get attacked by
one or either side of those of the of
the political spectrum right and so i
think yeah
no well i was i was going to say
what are the if we have an interest in
having some tools with which we can sort
of like pump the brakes when we start
getting sucked into some of these things
you you sort of alluded to some of these
things which is one is asking how big of
a problem is this really what are some
of the other questions that one can kind
of ask themselves as they start getting
pulled into some of these reactionary
loops
yeah i think the first and foremost
thing is to make sure that you have
principles and values that you're
following
rather than just reacting and seeing
something and saying oh that scares me
or i don't like that i'm gonna go on the
other side of that issue i think it's
really important for people to think
through
what are my values what is my political
project and what is the positive vision
that i have for the world
the second is being willing to consider
the possibility that you're wrong
i think it's really important for people
to understand that
they're not always right and one of the
amazing things about twitter is that we
can outsource
asking questions we can outsource we
only have one brain and when there's
millions of brains on twitter's on
twitter i think it's useful to think
okay maybe i'm wrong i need to really
consider what other people are pushing
back on me for or or the the ideas that
they're bringing to the table
and then the last one i think is to
avoid us versus them thinking um it's
really easy to fall into the trap where
you say this is my side i'm gonna agree
with everything on this side and
everyone who is on the other side of
this political issue or on the other
side of the political
divide
has bad motives or is wrong on every
single issue and so i think if you do
those three things one make sure you
have a positive vision um two
don't
don't um fall into us versus them
thinking and then three
um be able to consider the possibility
that you're wrong then you'll avoid this
this reactionary thinking that a lot of
people have fallen into what do you
suspect happened with someone like for
example dave rubin who you write about
in the article you know i i used to be
quite friendly with dave and we would
text and chat on the phone sometimes
years and years ago
and more recently you know he's attacked
me publicly he's
kind of sent me texts privately and like
my view has been
i don't know if he was like 38 or 40 at
the time that this political reawakening
kind of happened but i've not really met
people in my life whose politics so
dramatically changes at that age unless
they were almost like not even engaged
at all and they didn't even really have
like a formative politics so it's hard
for me to imagine that his views really
changed so it's easy to say
he was captured by the audience and he
was captured by you know getting to know
trump and this type of thing but i i
just don't really know what to make of
it like what's your sense of that
particular example
yeah it's hard to get into into people's
heads but generally what i think i think
happens to a lot of these people um
is that they go against well one i think
it's important to notice that the the
mid-2010s the early 2010s and when trump
came along there was a lot of social
change in terms of black lives matter
and there was a lot of this cultural
change that made people
fearful so i think that brought out a
certain type of person who maybe was
progressive on other issues but then
they realized that they maybe they're
more reactionary on these more cultural
issues
the second thing i think that happens a
lot is that maybe someone who's on the
left goes against
one of the progressive dogmas or one of
the progressive catechisms on these
progressive issues and then they get
really dog piled by people on the left
and they think whoa whoa
what is happening i thought these were
my allies i thought these were my
friends and then they kind of rather
than think having a somewhat rational
reaction and thinking okay either one
maybe i got this issue wrong or two
maybe the rest of my team is being a
little bit irrational on this this issue
they kind of jump to the other team and
then the other team or the other side
accepts them because
they say look now we have someone from
the left on our side right things think
that it gives them more credibility and
in a sense it does i mean these folks
are very useful to the right it seems to
me
yeah i think it is too because when
people when people on the right say look
we even have people on the left who are
joining us on this issue this issue this
issue and they once were really like the
young turks are a far progressive
left then they can say oh the left has
kind of just gone crazy on these issues
um and maybe maybe there is some time
for reflection on both sides like the
left could say really think through do
we need to be dog piling people who go
against us on one specific issue is it
really worth
ostracizing somebody and kicking them
out of our club just because they go
against one of these
one of our progressive dogmas
and and the the the people who are
leaving the left need to really
reconsider like are these the people
that i really truly align with on all my
political beliefs um or am i making just
kind of a
rash reaction to being attacked online
yeah i think both sides are important
the people doing the leaving should
really consider whether they're aligning
with with the right people but the
people putting in place the litmus or
purity test should also kind of kind of
consider the impact of that we've been
speaking with seth moskowitz who's a
journalist writing about american
politics and technology he's an editor
at persuasion magazine and we'll link to
his article the reactionary trap seth i
really appreciate your time today thank
you very much i appreciate being here
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show so this
you really have to see to believe this
this is just out of this world a bizarre
tucker carlson the fox news propagandist
has been promoting a forthcoming then
forthcoming special on masculinity and
testosterone
that is going to
i guess shed light on the crisis of
masculinity that tucker says exists
and
talk about the issues with
decreased testosterone in men which we
will get to in a moment and it's all
really weird and one of the things that
many people noticed about the uh promo
for the thing
was that it's quote homoerotic now again
like i don't
i to say it's to say something is
homoerotic pejoratively is kind of
homophobic and i don't think that's what
the commentaries were here it's pointing
out
this is all about
restoring men in the image
that tucker carlson and other right
wingers see men as being expected to
hold
and yet the promo
seemed much more
in line maybe with
i i don't know with with gay men it's
it's not even really clear like exactly
what the commentary was but i'm gonna
play the promo for you and it is
certainly strange it doesn't exactly
seem like the prototypical alpha male
idea of tucker's audience so take a look
at this to start with
[Music]
so there's like a there was like a naked
guy with like a light on his testicles
and then now there's now there's like
half naked guys exercising
once the society collapses then
you're in hard times well
hard iron sharpens iron as they say and
those hard times inevitably
produce men who are tough men who are
resourceful men who are strong enough to
survive
and then they go on to re-establish
order and so the cycle begins again
the end of men is the is the name of it
and it all
if i told if you told me david check out
this satire of a fox news special about
masculinity and you showed me that i'd
go wow that's a really funny satire but
it's real so the special has aired
and there was a fitness expert brought
on to explain how to raise testosterone
levels in men and the topic comes up
of
testicle tanning tanning your testicles
you saw in the clip there if you want to
optimize and take it
to another level expose yourself to red
light therapy yes um and the juve
that we were using in the documentary
there's a massive amount of testicle
tanning it's testicle tanning but it's
also full body uh red light therapy
which has massive amount of benefits and
there's so much data out there um that
isn't being picked up on or covered so
obviously half the viewers right now are
like what that's testiculating that's
crazy
but my view is okay testosterone levels
crash and nobody says anything about it
that's crazy
so why is it crazy to seek solutions
it's not crazy to seek solutions and i
think um i was recently exposed to a
term called bromiopathy and i think
there's a lot of people out there right
now that
um
are don't trust the mainstream
information yeah now i wouldn't call it
bromeopathy i think what he's looking
for is bromeopathy like homeopathy
either way it's it's not very funny now
to be clear
red light therapy for testosterone
is being studied and there are reports
saying it might do something or it might
not
but this isn't even a doctor this is a
guy branded a fitness professional and
the entire thing is so bizarre and they
always bring in this undertone we can't
trust the official stuff
what we're being told can't be believed
so therefore
you got to start tanning your balls bro
and the next guest afterwards was kid
rock the right wing musician
and he
even kid rock was like is this all a
joke that's when you know it's weird
when even kid rock can't take it
seriously [ __ ] ladies and gentlemen
so our dude our cameraman i i guess
scott fox is in your house right now
he is dude stop testicle tanning come on
i'm starting a punk rock band and it's
called testicle tanning that's the end
of it
i think you'll be massively successful
but i mean don't you think at this point
when so many of the therapies the paths
they've told us to take have turned out
to be dead ends that have really hurt
people why is kid rock being interviewed
about this like kid rock doesn't know
anything about media literacy kid rock
doesn't know anything about medicine
it's a crazy premise to bring on kid
rock to comment on testicle tanning
fitness pro why wouldn't
open-minded people seek new solutions
i i don't know what the hell is going on
in this world i'm not even sure if i
understood that question but some days i
just want to stop exactly no he didn't
kid rock doesn't even understand the
question that tucker carlson is asking
him now let's interject some reality
here a good question is are the premises
even true
are testosterone levels decreasing now
the answer is yes
but it's not exactly clear why or what
it means so there's been a bunch of
studies
done over several decades and it does
appear as though testosterone levels are
decreasing in men
at a given age like we know about over
time in for an individual as one ages
testosterone levels decrease but there
is something different going on which is
men of a particular age today
seem to have slightly lower testosterone
levels than men of the same age at some
period in the past so
it appears to be decreasing then the
question is why
and the cause is not actually known but
there's a bunch of different ideas one
aspect of this could be external toxins
and something environmental we know that
there's lots of products out there that
have endocrine disruption potential and
we know certain things can affect female
fertility so there could be things in
the environment that affect men's
testosterone levels that's one
possibility another piece appears to be
untreated depression we we have pretty
good
data that untreated depression pushes
down testosterone levels we have both
stigma around mental health treatment in
the united states as well as lack of
access to mental health treatment in the
united states you don't treat depression
if depression decreases decreases
testosterone you would expect to see
decreased testosterone obesity is very
high in the united states and moderate
obesity
seems to diminish
testosterone due to what's called
insulin resistance associated reductions
in the sex hormone binding globulin okay
so that that maybe obesity may be a
factor here men with diabetes are more
likely to have low testosterone it's not
clear whether it's a cause effect
correlation causation so there is an
issue and it's being explored by medical
doctors a decrease in testosterone
but tucker's friend kid rock and a
fitness professional aren't going to be
the ones to solve it they're also not
the authorities on this and the maybe
the most important thing is
they frame this as a cultural issue of
[ __ ] men like when the right talks
about the end of men
and decrease testosterone
they're talking about
[ __ ] men men that don't meet the
prototypical emblematic image of what a
manly man is supposed to be what's
particularly funny is tucker doesn't
meet that standard either right i mean
like like i i don't care about these uh
standards and these ideas but tucker
as the privileged
sort of
you know i think dandy might be the word
that's that's applied bow tie wearing i
mean he had you know tasseled in that
interview he had tasseled you you can
even kind of see it tasseled loafers
with no socks like he he's not the guy
that meets neither is trump right and so
that's what's also very strange about
this now just as a bonus clip
here's a preview of another upcoming
tucker carlson special where he brings
on two butchers to talk about the idea
that extraterrestrials are mutilating
cattle this is the next special
you have to have the right tools
so and you have to have the right knife
with the right edge on it because if you
don't have a sharp knife you're never
going to be able to achieve you know you
might be able to achieve it but it but
it's going to look like you didn't know
what you were doing so if these animals
have been found with their you know
these pieces surgically removed
and you know not making a lot of hack
marks when you're cutting somebody knows
what they're doing right so that's it so
assess the difficulty here so we've
heard well it must be some satanic cult
that has been operating i guess for
centuries in countries around the world
but whoever's doing this knows a lot
about the anatomy of these animals and
it's high skill is that correct yes and
frankly butchers with a skill level like
ours are becoming less and less frequent
in the united states so even finding a
butcher that this is so stupid so that's
the next special the bearded butcher
twins or brothers will explain to you
how
there are cuts being made to cattle that
suggest maybe extraterrestrial origin
fox news tucker carlson specials
specials which are now airing hey this
is fascinating news and many of you i
know will take great pleasure in this
alex jones's infowars has filed for
bankruptcy now i'm going to tell you
right up front
this stinks to high heaven and you're
gonna start to figure out why in a
moment but here's the report from
reuters
far right wing website infowars
yesterday sunday
filed for voluntary chapter 11
bankruptcy protection
in the face of multiple defamation
lawsuits chapter 11 bankruptcy puts a
hold on all civil litigation matters and
allows companies to prepare turnaround
plans while remaining operational
alex jones founder of infowars was found
liable for damages in a trio of lawsuits
last year after he falsely claimed the
2012 sandy hook school massacre was a
hoax
jones claimed the shooting in which 20
children and six school employees were
shot dead was fabricated by gun control
advocates
sandy hook families in late march
rejected his offer to settle and reopen
the case jones offered to pay 120 grand
to each of the 13 plaintiffs each of the
plaintiffs turned it down
infowars listed its estimated assets in
the range of zero
to fifty thousand dollars and estimated
liabilities in the range of one to ten
million dollars
infowars reportedly made
165 million dollars over three years
according to records so
right away many of you emailed me with
the exact thought that i had is this a
fraudulent bankruptcy has money just
been moved and moved and moved and
difficult to track ways and now alex
jones is saying we don't have any money
and we're bankrupt and we're not going
to be able to pay anybody is that really
what's going on i don't know it does
stink and if you have revenues of 165
million over three years
fifty thousand dollars you know
that's a rounding error it is difficult
to believe that a company with a you
know 50 million 55 million dollars a
year in revenue doesn't even have 50
grand in cash on hand now he claims that
liabilities are between 1 and 10 million
dollars so is it possible that all of
the legal fees have drained the info
wars reserves i don't know but it smells
very very funky if there's any real
false flag operation
it's more likely that it's alex jones
lying about not having any money than it
is the things he said about sandy hook
so hopefully the court will assign a
forensic accountant to look at if and
when money was moved
because he knew the court was going to
take the money and give it to people in
settlements um it is not if you have
competent
counsel lawyers and accountants
it's it's shockingly easy
to make money disappear into you know a
black hole of overseas accounts and it
would really take a lot of work to track
it down
so
i don't know what's going on it would be
in some sense delightful to see such a
corrosive media influence no longer be
financially viable and when i say that
it's like you know i don't wish for
people to get coveted and die
i don't wish for people to be unable to
feed themselves by not having any money
but
the world would be better off without
infowars and without alex jones
supplements being sold and that's a
large
share of the money that they make so
the truth of this bankruptcy i i
genuinely have no idea
i think you're right to be skeptical as
many of you who emailed me are
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here's a caller who wants some clarity
on
yiddish and jewish words so of course
when people need clarity on that i guess
they call me
hi david uh i'm from alabama okay and
this is a genuine question uh i just
don't meet many jewish people so pardon
my ignorance but i hear the term
schmeckle sometimes and
does that mean
penis or money okay and i'm not trolling
here i'm seriously asking because
sometimes they hear in the context of
okay they're definitely talking about
their
phallic region but um i just don't know
man okay so here's the deal there's two
similar sounding words the words are
schmeckl and shekel okay
schmeckel
means little penis in yiddish schmeckle
shekel
means money shekels were silver coins
used in ancient israel and the middle
east
it's now the currency of israel the new
israeli shekel the latter shekel is
sometimes used anti-semitically so for
example i mean you have to these are
often dog whistles so you have to
understand the context when you see like
these right wingers go
you know
all of these heads of media outlets and
film studios hoarding their shekels
when they say that they're saying
these jewish ceos hoarding money so
sometimes sheckle is used as a dog
whistle it is the new israeli shekel the
current currency in the state of israel
all right so hopefully that is
illuminating on the bonus show today are
there going to be presidential debates
in 2024 maybe not and we'll tell you why
there's an austin texas
basic income program that's
going to give struggling residents
a thousand dollars a month
and there are concerns about senator
dianne feinstein i'll tell you what
those concerns are
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show sign up at
joinpacman.com to get instant access i
will see you there
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors cheese butter is
the delicious gourmet cheese melt that
blends four indulgent cheeses and
seasoned butter i love this stuff
perfect on bread bagels sandwiches
veggies and more and you'll get 20 off
when you go to cheesebutter.com
pacman the link is down below